he's brett favre how are you brett how
you been man I'm good rich I thought you
were gonna talk about me and my legs
well I'm more than happy to do that you
could you can extend to play with your
legs Brett you could do that uh you know
it's a it's a distant memory but I think
I did well you know what it's
interesting I thought you this weekend
to Brett because when I saw Mariota
catch his own pass for his first career
touchdown in plows that was your your
first ever pass attempt in the league
right correct you caught him yeah yeah I
didn't I didn't catch a touchdown I
thought I was going to catch a touchdown
but I had I ended up losing like seven
yards I was uh yeah I was second half
came in against Tampa Bay put me in they
were killing us I throw it yeah tipped
it I caught it and needless to say
homeroom was not happy when I got to the
sidelines hey but at least didn't go for
an interception I guess that's right all
right you know so did you watch any of
the national champion game last night we
were able to catch some of it yeah I did
what a great game you know I you know I
didn't talk to Georgia Oklahoma game
last week but it was it was a close
second what a great game what'd you
think of that kid
what'd you think of that kid - I thought
he pointed I thought he played
outstanding you know he gave him a spark
you know and I thought Jalen Hurd first
of all handled himself about his class
as you could handle yourself but that
kid did nothing but help himself I mean
he was tremendous you know and and I
give my hat to Nick Saban and mold coach
who I think the world of brian de bal i
thought did a heck of a job call him
plays and he did a fantastic job putting
him in in good position to to succeed
and yeah i mean it was a it was a great
move
and they may have won the game anyway
who knows but right he gave him a spark
that that they needed at that time Brett
Favre joining me here on the Rich Eisen
show want to hit John a couple other
items before we talk about your
documentary speaking of old coaches
going back what do you think of Gruden's
contract going back to coach the Raiders
read what I mean I don't know what else
you can say but Wow
you know what a contract and you know I
was asked to question numerous times but
my friends and family is is he worth it
and I said who is worth it you know what
player what coach's worth what they get
paid but it's not you know it's not
John's fault it's not a player's fault
you you know you you have a body of work
and people are I to believe in it no
they don't and and John is he's an
outstanding coach there's no doubt his
commitment to to the game is as good if
not better than anyone's and so you know
the only thing and he knows this the
expectation expectation level is at
times some it seems almost unreachable
for a player or coach and you know there
much will be expected of John and he
knows that but you know it'll be
interesting I'm curious to see how he
does and I think you'll do a great job
there and Brady broke a lot of your
records for 40 year old quarterbacks
this past year Brett Farve what did you
think of Brady's performance this year
and do you think he's gonna win it all
when it's all said and done this year
yeah I was not surprised by anything I
now or in the future
anything that Tom does I think he's you
know I never thought I'd say someone was
better than Joe Montana but that Joe Joe
Montana has always been the best
quarterback that I've ever seen and tom
has has surpassed that and I not taking
anything away from Joe Tom just gets
better
you know regardless of who's in there
playing with him you know which which is
hard to find chemistry well when you
with your plugging guys in there but but
he and Belichick have managed to do it
at the highest level as consistent as
anyone has ever done it and I don't see
any reason why Tom Wolfe will diminish
anytime soon and I I don't foresee them
being beat you know I think that they
had to have the team that won it all
this year and I'm I wouldn't bet against
them again next year
Brett Favre Pro Football Hall of Famer
and part of the new documentary shock
the hidden factor in sports concussion
crisis here on the Rich Eisen show and
now Brady's got some help from James
Harrison whose movement from the
Steelers to the Patriots may also made
me thinking you Brett because the only
person I could think of that could
similarly go from one spot to another
and then have a fan base that's been
rooting for him forever wonder what was
given then then you going from Green Bay
to Minnesota is there any any sort of
advice you'd give Steelers fans and
Harrison about the future based on your
your career path right well you know I
think you know if we didn't know it we
we certainly should should know it and
realize it by now that anything can and
will happen and I remember thinking when
Joe Montana was was traded to the chief
I thought the world was coming to an end
I could not believe what I was seeing
and I I just I I just couldn't believe
it
and little did I know that that same
thing what happened to me you know later
later on and so you know strange things
happen and you know we don't know
exactly what took place between James
Harrison and the Steelers if anything
maybe it was a mutual effort yeah
there's there's talk here and there of
this and that but you really don't know
but what you do know is New England felt
strongly enough to
to sign him right away and what first
week it pays off in just two sacks yeah
and sometimes you know a change of
scenery is not only good for the player
but it's good for the team that lets you
go but also for the team that picks you
up and you know and then there are times
where it's not you you know it it's it
has an adverse effect but I would say
right now if the the benefit has gone to
the Patriots the spark if they needed
one it has been added by you know
signing Harrison so but I mean you know
you don't rule the Steelers out by any
stretch of the imagination
they're still a very good football team
and it would be curious to see what you
know what happens and and on how James
plays and and how they handle that whole
situation if they play against each
other here daddy the next couple weeks
that certainly would be something so
let's talk about this this documentary
do you have on a daily basis semi daily
or not at all concussion effects from
your playing career right you know as it
is with with diagnosing concussions I
mean we see a guy get knocked out cold
it mean we all can diagnose that as a
concussion but it's what you don't see I
think that's what's scary you know I can
I mean I couldn't even tell you how many
times my ears were ringing I saw stars
little fogginess that was pretty much
every time I got hit or my head hits a
turf and I'm sure most players could say
that and what we're finding out is you
know that's as bad if not worse than
then you know the the knockout blow and
so I think symptoms are are kind of iffy
as well I mean forgetting things I when
I will say this I don't
have headaches every day I don't have
dizziness forgetfulness yes am I going
to write that off is 48 years old or too
many blows to the head I think is a
combination of a lot of things I think
as we get older you know where's my car
keys and they're in your hand
where's my glasses they're on top of
your head you know I think that's that's
a common as you get older type of thing
that we all face but you know I have to
admit for playing 20 years I really
can't complain I don't know what normal
feels like but I but I can't complain so
what do you want people to take away
from this documentary again that's going
to be on the new multi-platform Sports
Network Stadium watch Stadium calm on
Thursday at 6:30 p.m. Eastern well I
think if people will watch it I think
they're going to be for lack of a better
term shocked not not anything that I
would say or do but there there are
other parts to this documentary it's not
very long that that kids you know a more
fearful out look at concussions and and
as if it hasn't been bad enough already
but this company Brock who I think the
world of has done an unbelievable job of
studying testing building all the
science technology behind this shock pad
that they have put under artificial
surfaces that has reduced concussions by
a considerable percentage and one in
five concussions are when your head hits
the turf and I know I can I can speak
volumes on that and so no one has really
looked at the playing surface as as a
piece of equipment that you wear or like
a piece of equipment and that that's the
way it should be
looked at rather than all the grass
looks great look at the logo it's
beautiful it's a slow it's a fast
surface you know I think you need to
look at it as this is equipment just
like a helmet and so when you when you
watch this documentary it's not about
selling a product as much as it is there
is something better and safer out there
that can be provided mainly for our
youth and I got three grandsons and if
I'm not going to encourage them to play
football I'm not going to discourage
them but I would much rather be a caddy
form and golf then watch him play
football because you know and that's
crazy I mean people say I can't believe
he would say that but you know head
injuries or are going to continue the
quality of player is only going to go up
and that means concussions are not going
to go down and so it's a scary issue
Brett I really appreciate the time man
also appreciate I know you connected
with Baker may feel right because he he
came on the show and said I want to chat
with pear right you guys connected right
oh yeah we connected well you know I
what a what an exciting player and watch
and did it did an outstanding job
definitely worthy at the Heisman Trophy
you know now it's time for him to move
on to something bigger and better I
think you'll do a fine job in the NFL
all right Brett right yeah he was all
fired up to get the chance to talk to
you and I always appreciate when you
call and best to Deanna happy New Year
to you and yours and all the kids and
grandkids we'll chat soon hopefully
oh okay rich always great talking with
you necklace you got that spread far Pro
Football Hall of Famer would rather his
grandsons be caddies for golf the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience